doch dieses wort verwirrt viele deutsch
lerner und ein grund dafür ist dass
dieses wort ganz unterschiedliche
funktionen hat bzw es zu drei
unterschiedlichen wortarten gehört doch
ist einmal eine konjunktion es ist ein
ab werk und es ist auch ein modell
partikel und das macht doch so
kompliziert
bei unserem meetup in manchester vor
einigen wochen haben wir james kennen
gelernt selbst unser petrol und ehrt uns
vorgeschlagen macht doch mal ein video
zu diesem thema und für james und die
vielen anderen von euch die doch immer
noch verwirrend finden machen wir heute
dieses video
los geht's
die erste wort bzw die erste funktion
von doch ist doch als konjunktion doch
kann eine konjunktion sein also zwei
sätze oder zwei satzteile miteinander
verbinden
ihr erkennt doch als konjunktion daran
dass sie dass es am anfang eines
nebensatz besteht also meistens nach
einem komma er stellt eine frage
er erwartet eine antwort doch statt
beantwort hat ihr erstmal einen blöden
spruch hier habt ihr ein beispiel
gesehen von einem satz den ich selber
vor einiger zeit hier gesagt habe und
hier benutze ich doch als konjunktion
und zwar als konjunktion die eigentlich
die gleiche bedeutung hat wie aber ihr
könnt also doch in diesen satz auch mit
aber besetzen und daran erkennt jedoch
als konjunktion doch als konjunktion ist
genau wie aber als konjunktion die
zweite wort bzw die zweite funktion ist
doch als adverb doch keine antwort sein
und hat dann eine ganz andere bedeutung
als doch als konjunktion als abwehr
bedeutet doch so etwas wie trotzdem oder
im gegenteil
und es wird immer dann benutzt wenn eine
aussage verneint ist und ihr
widersprochen wird oder wenn eine
aussage wenn man etwas nicht machen kann
oder nicht machen will und es dann aber
trotzdem macht hier ist ein beispiel
also manchmal würde ich gerne kein
trinkgeld geben machst dann meistens
aber doch und ärger mich danach in
diesem beispiel seht ihr einen mann und
er sagt dass er eigentlich kein
trinkgeld geben will und dann macht er
ist aber doch in diesen satz kann man
doch auch mit trotzdem oder dennoch
ersetzen man kann also zum beispiel
sagen ich mache es dann aber meistens
trotzdem und ärgere mich danach oder ich
mach's dann aber einfach dennoch und
ärgere mich dann
also doch hat in diesem fall die gleiche
funktion oder die gleiche übersetzung
wie trotzdem
doch wird auch immer dann benutzt wenn
man einer negativen aussage widerspricht
du lernst kein deutsch oder doch tue ich
und wichtig ist dass man aber nur
negative aussagen mit doch widersprechen
kann wenn ich zum beispiel sage du
willst heute abend zu hause bleiben dann
antworte ich darauf nein will ich nicht
wenn ich jedoch diese aussage negativ
frage nämlich du willst heute abend
nicht mitgehen dann antworte ich mit
doch du willst heute abend nicht
mitgehen doch will ich die deutschland
machen kann doch aber das ist ein
anderes lebensgefühl was wir haben auch
in diesem beispiel ist doch eine
verneinung der negativen aussage am ihr
fragt die deutschen machen keine party
und sie antwortet doch die deutschland
machen keine bord doch aber das ist ein
anderes lebensgefühl was wir haben
wenn doch in einem satz benutzt wird
bedeutet es manchmal auch dass man etwas
getan hat oder tut was man eigentlich
nicht tun wollte oder nicht tun durfte
ich bin gestern abend doch ins kino
gegangen
diese aussage bedeutet dass ich
eigentlich nicht ins kino gehen wollte
vielleicht habe ich dir gesagt ich
wollte gar nicht heute abend ins kino
gehen am nächsten tag sage ich dir dann
aber ich bin gestern abend doch ins kino
gegangen
dieses doch drückt also einen
widerspruch aus und verneint auch hier
eine aussage aber mit einer tieferen
bedeutung also einer vorgeschichte mit
der dritten wort bzw der dritte funktion
von doch wird es richtig kompliziert
denn doch kann nicht nur eine
konjunktion sein oder ein adverb sondern
doch kann auch ein modell partikel seien
und wie ihr vielleicht schon gehört
absinth modell
etwas kompliziert denn modal partikel
sind satz glieder die es in vielen
sprachen gar nicht gibt und die deshalb
auch nicht richtig übersetzt werden
können man übersetzt sie nicht weil sie
auch meistens keine direkte übersetzung
haben sondern sie drücken viel mehr eine
motivation oder eine stimmung aus oder
bieten einen kontext zu einem satz auch
als modell partikel kann doch
unterschiedliche funktionen haben
es gibt insgesamt vier funktionen die
häufigste funktion ist das doch als
verstärkung fungiert und zwar als
verstärkung von aussagen
meistens jedoch als verstärkung von
aufforderungen des publikums lag fast
eigentlich der ganze doch mal wird klar
wie klaus beschreibt uns doch bitte was
du machst ja ich nehme der schnitte hier
habt ihr zwei beispiele aus unserem
schnitzel video gesehen und beides mal
wird doch als verstärkung einer
aufforderung benutzt klaus sagt zum
beispiel zu mir erzählt doch mal einen
witz kari er könnte auch sagen erzählen
mal einen witz carey oder erzählt einen
witz kari aber mit diesem doch verstärkt
er noch diese aufforderung an mich denn
ich habe ihn gerade gesagt dass es
langweilig ist ihm zuzuschauen beim
schnitzel klopfen und dann sagt er dass
so ein bisschen als scherz mir ging
immer dann erzählt doch einen witz carré
die zweite funktion von doch als modell
partikel ist dass es unmut oder
verwunderung ausdrücken kann wie in
diesem beispiel mein highlight der woche
gott die woche fängt doch erst am morgen
dieser mann wurde gerade gefragt was das
highlight seiner woche sei und er
antwortet wieso die woche hat doch
gerade erst angefangen
er drückt also mit dem doch eine
verwunderung aus es gibt noch zwei
weitere funktionen hierauf werden wir
nicht so sehr ein gehen denn sie kommen
weniger häufig vor
eine davon ist dass man mit doch eine
hoffnung auf eine zustimmung ausdrücken
kann ich kann zum beispiel sagen du
kommst doch heute abend oder das
bedeutet dass ich mir wünsche dass du
heute abend kommt und mit diesem doch
kann ich diesen wunsch verstärken eine
vierte funktion von doch als modell
partikel ist dass es ausdrücken kann
dass ich etwas weiß aber diese sache mir
gerade nicht einfällt wenn ich mich zum
beispiel mit dir treffe und wir reden
über deine katze aber ich habe den namen
deiner katze vergessen dann kann ich
sagen
wie heißt deine katze doch gleich das
wäre ein beispiel für die vierte
funktion zu diesem letzten thema modal
partikel haben wir auch schon ein ganzes
video gemacht und darin werdet ihr auch
beispiele zu doch und zu anderen modell
partikeln finden
dieses ganze video seht ihr hier also
ich fasse noch mal für euch zusammen
doch kann eine konjunktion sein
ein adverb und ein modell partikel all
diese drei worte haben unterschiedliche
übersetzungen und funktionen und die
modelle partikel haben sogar noch mal
verschiedene funktionen und deshalb
solltet ihr euch auch keine sorgen
machen wenn ihr schon ganz gut deutsch
spricht aber doch immer noch nicht ganz
versteht oder vielleicht nicht wisst
wann ihr doch anwenden könnt und wir
werden euch aber ermutigen das weiter zu
lernen um so länger ihr deutsch spricht
oder vor allem um so länger ihr in
deutschland lebt wird euch das wort
häufiger begegnen und dann werdet ihr
auch sicherer im umgang damit sein wenn
ihr noch ein bisschen sicherer jetzt
direkt werden möchtet dann könnt ihr
auch unsere übungen zu dem thema machen
als katrin erhaltet ihr jede woche
übungen meistens zu unseren sonntags
videos und für dieses video und dieses
thema doch haben wir ein extra übungs
blatt ein interaktives übungsplatz für
euch erstellt und dort könnt ihr noch
einmal euer
wissen zum thema testen und gucken in
welchen setzen kann man doch an wänden
war nicht welche funktionen hat doch das
ganze könnt ihr machen wenn ihr ein
päckchen werdet für einen dollar die
woche seid ihr ein mitglied dann bei uns
und bekommt interaktive übungen jede
woche über 150 übungsblätter haben wir
dort schon hier könnt ihr sie german
abonnieren und wir freuen uns auch wenn
wir nächste woche wieder dabei sein
bis bald
[Musik]